hello and welcome to another episode of
footnotes which I explore the most
ravishing language and ideas from the
last week of Wired first up today it
seems like the animals are upset with us
hogging all the top hats why design put
out a gallery of the strangest taxidermy
you can find on etsy a lot of which are
animals trying to act like humans one of
them even has a mohawk though I suppose
horses also have natural Mohawks so it's
not an exclusively human thing doesn't
matter this humanization of non-human
ideas objects and creatures is called
anthropomorphism the term which means
human form was coined by the greek
philosopher sanaa phonies he was
objecting to the practice of giving
God's human shapes though he should have
admitted that it could have been much
worse the gods could have been appearing
as their respective names
anthropomorphism is so commonplace that
we never really noticed it we almost
expect animals to have some sort of
human qualities for instance the other
day I say bird with a cigarette in its
mouth and all I could think was that
bird is looking cool and that's a bit
troubling anthropomorphism can also be
very dangerous as it breaks down the
natural boundaries between humans and
beasts you may think that it's fine to
put a bow tie on a chimp but you have to
realize you've just given a little
rascal something to strangle you with
humanizing animals might also be excited
loneliness it's theorized that
anthropomorphizing a pet with something
like a sweater it's a subconscious
attempt to create a human-like friend
only it's a friend without pants and
that's no friend at all I'd be nothing
but a savage if I didn't touch on the
landing of a curiosity rover on Mars wyd
science had excellent coverage of the
event I want to expand on that a bit and
talk about Mars as we've understood it
over the centuries Edwin Starr once
asked war hooah yeah what is it good for
absolutely nothing except for describing
Mars associating war with the planet is
surprisingly consistent across eastern
and western cultures this derives on the
planets reddish hue which comes to mean
blood or fire but apparently not nice
things like strawberries and
it wasn't until the late 1800s the
telescope's got powerful enough to show
Mars in detail an Italian astronomer
cleared the first map of the surface in
1877 finding not strawberries or fires
but canals kind of like Venice has only
without Indiana Jones flying around
making a mess of things except they
weren't canals it was an optical
illusion but this got people thinking
that perhaps the canals had been dug by
intelligent life-forms the Martians and
they were probably very ornery as an hg
wells classic the war of the worlds in
which Tom Cruise ruins a perfectly good
book one can only hope that NASA
includes speakers on curiosity the blast
this recording to thoroughly confuse any
Martians then we hand out cigarettes
ties and sweaters and pants
Oh